hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen mio als ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut tut mir leid
werden uns wieder ein bisschen länger
nicht gesehen ich schwöre aber es kommen
jetzt viele videos mindestens zwei oder
drei die woche übermorgen kommt schon
das nächste und wir starten auch direkt
mal wieder mit einem richtig richtig
kasse neuen thema was ist noch nie auf
youtube wo er das gibt es ja schon acht
es gibt ja ach so das gibt es schon am
ist das gibt es ja schon das ding ist
ich beschäftige mich in letzter zeit so
viel mit online-shopping und so und ich
habe mitbekommen media markt saturn die
hatten ja auch im lockdown alle zu du
konntest als geschäftskunde glaube ich
da hin wenn du vorher anruft oder
irgendwie so auf jeden fall gibt es
extrem viele anzeigen mit waren
überschuss es gibt eine menge neue
saturn wunder typen sogar für 99.000
euro kannst du so einen lkw bestellen
ja das ist wahrscheinlich noch ein
bisschen zu weit von mir entfernt aber
während ich jetzt hier schon mal die
produkte hierhin hole kann ich das ja
mal sagen mein ziel ist es schon im
nächsten monat einmal so ein 11.000 euro
paket zu bestellen also ohne witzig flex
jetzt hier nicht so unnötig rum ich
mache das wirklich ja auch wenn das das
fashion next level ich dachte mir aber
trotzdem wir starten hier noch mal
entspannt reihen mit einem 500 euro
paket das sind zwei pakete die sind hier
angekommen
die haben einen garantierten mindestwert
von 1000 euro also wenn es gut läuft
auch über 1000 euro und bis jetzt ist ja
schon mal eine menge an waren dafür wir
starten einfach mal mit diesem paket
hier rein
das wirkt so auf mich so ein bisschen
sperrig also ich gehe es halt nicht
davon aus dass da irgendwie ein
hochwertiges handy oder so drin ist ich
bin mal gespannt
let's go was gerade noch sagen wollte
ich habe in der zwischen das ist ja nur
ein produkt drin was soll das denn ich
habe in der zwischenzeit gesehen der
youtuber klängen dann hat auch ein video
dazu gemacht und seinen karton hat
gefloppt deswegen kann es sein dass vor
weihnachten wirklich geile sachen da
drin waren dagegen ja auch dieses
wiederum von offen und ehrlich darauf
habe ich reagiert dass das alles fake
sei vor allem die videos die chris prima
zu dem thema gemacht hat und dass es
sozusagen abgesprochen war mit saturn
wie auch immer ist er ist einfach nur
nein das glaube ich oder hier ist ja
einfach nur ein staubsauger drin aber
das ist ja
an bestimmten wert von der staubsauger
oder bosch wie heißt das ringen athlet
serie
achso auf deutsch athlet serie 6 pro
animal 28 volt er alles klar
ja gut das ding ist das staubsauger
angeht bin ich sehr gut bedient ich bin
euch hier auch jetzt immer den neupreis
davon ein aber der wird ja jetzt nicht
für 100 euro kosten oder einen plan
na ja ich würde ganz gerne mal
vorsichtig auf machen den sauger ja gut
dann muss man halt komplett
zusammenbauen nochmal so sieht das aus
leute also im internet habe ich den für
220 euro gesehen
das kann ich für den natürlich nicht
mehr verlangen ihr müsst ihr auch wissen
ich muss halt auch ganz ehrlich sagen
ich versuche die sachen schon zum teil
zu verkaufen damit ich damit halt auch
wieder neue projekte finanzieren kann
weil sonst ist es halt einfach viel zu
teuer wenn ich das einfach immer
verschenken würde danach oder soja ich
hoffe dass können überstehen also wenn
in dem anderen paket da jetzt auch nur
eine sache drin ist dann wird es ein
wirklich sehr sehr kurzes video alter
dass das sieht jetzt aber gar nicht
schön aus das ist ja total dreckig wo
was sie denn unterwegs sagt okay ich bin
erstmal es sieht auf den ersten blick
ganz gut aus als wäre hier mehr sachen
drin als in dem ja mein alter und man
was ich aber als erstes wahrgenommen hat
monster junge diese kopfhörer
ich habe die mal im laden gesehen für 39
euro 99 glaube ich habe ich ja auch aufs
zimmer testen das war wirklich nicht gut
also für 40 euro viel zu teuer
15 euro stabil 20 euro vielleicht auch
noch aber 40 euro dafür ist viel zu
teuer leute ganz cool sich hatten wir
eben im internet recherchiert und zwar
seht ihr hier die gibt es wirklich für 8
und also das ist viel zu teuer für die
kauft euch die nicht für das geld die
sind scheiße und das beste ist natürlich
davon ist wie viele dinger sind wir drin
okay es sind insgesamt 31 teil kopfhörer
gut ich kann mir gerade einen von diesen
dingern aufmachen
vielleicht sind das ja auch neue und ich
habe damals nicht aber nicht ich habe ja
lange zeit airports wechsel testet das
ist nicht das ist schon nicht gut ich
gehe mal davon aus dass sie nicht so
lange halten können trotzdem mal kurz
der sound geht zwar halbwegs klar aber
dafür so viel geld zu verlangen also das
safe zu teuer da muss ich schon sagen
habe ich mich über den staubsauger mehr
gefreut
besser als nix kommt man kann es hier so
schön als pyramide aufstellen und dann
machen wir weiter
hiermit ich hoffe ja irgendwo darunter
verbirgt sich noch ein handy hier haben
wir ein seagate game 3 2 terabyte ab das
ist für die ps4 sonne festplatte
wahrscheinlich ich bin euch hier habe
ich ja schon gesagt immer den preis an
ich glaube so ein ding kostet auch auf
jeden fall über 50 euro auch nicht
schlecht und das beste wir haben das
gleich zweimal
ja okay ich weiß nicht mal das papier
aus acht sehr gut leute aktuelles thema
ein fiba einen termin termin nennt sich
das fieber gemessen geht ja aktuell am
flughafen in irgendwelchen
einkaufspassagen wahrscheinlich in
zukunft auch wo auch immer deswegen kann
man mit so etwas sicherlich viel
anfangen
ich habe jetzt keine verwendung für aber
gut danke dafür saturn das ganze kommt
übrigens hier ist auch wieder eine
quittung dabei die schauen wir uns am
ende mal an das kommt vom saturn neu
isenburg ich habe allerdings auch noch
extrem viele angebote vom saturn in
frankfurt ohne in münchen media markt
auch ganz viel man kann für 2500 euro
auch media markt rest ware kaufen dass
wir auf jeden fall auf eine sache ihr
könnt super gerne kommentieren was der
alex als nächstes bestellen soll weil
ich muss auch dazu sagen wenn ich ein
paar sachen von diesen sachen eventuell
verkaufen wir haben hier noch die power
beats die waren auch noch drin
von der marke beats ja ich glaube schon
ganz gut und auch nicht günstig deswegen
stelle ich die auch mal hierzu und hier
noch ein rasierer den kann ich
eigentlich sogar selber behalten wobei
ich mir vor zwei wochen ersten neuen
rasierer gekauft habt weswegen aber ich
bin mit dem man nicht so ganz zufrieden
ich weiß nicht ich bin so gespannt was
das für ein wert wenn ich das alles
hochrechne aber ich glaube es täglich
über 1000 euro was ich auf jeden fall
gerade noch sagen wollte dass ich noch
2100 euro von meinem restposten projekt
aus dem dezember hat das geld habe ich
noch nicht angerührt und wenn ich dann
hier mit irgendwie 2600 habt könnte ich
mit 2500 euro oder vielleicht auch für
3000 euro was kaufen und irgendwann dann
halt auch für 11.000 wie ich mache ich
denke schon richtig voraus hier haben
wir noch einen philips compact solution
was ist denn das hand hält das ist eine
tragbare dampf
weltweite nummer eins wahrscheinlich zum
bügeln oder so ne und das war's dann
leider auch schon aber moment ich habe
nämlich das leichte gefühl das ist auf
jeden fall einen flop war die boxen die
ich im dezember und november ausgepackt
habt waren auf jeden fall deutlich
besser und 1000 euro haben wir hier
glaube ich nicht oder ich sehe es gerade
hier werden zum beispiel diese kopfhörer
mit 869 euro angegeben also das finde
ich frei weil ich bin mir sicher im
laden haben die 40 gekostet und
sonnenschutz ist nicht 70 euro wert also
das ist schon abzocke und sonst aber im
großen und ganzen in ordnung ich muss
sagen ein teil davon werde ich auf jeden
fall auf meinem neuen restposten shop
lucky dog ii.de anbieten für gutes geld
dass ich ein bisschen was von den ganzen
kosten wieder raus habe womit ich dann
auch neue projekte finanzieren kann
das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht mal so
schlecht und ich hoffe dass es ab jetzt
nur noch kassa wir aber mal schauen was
als nächstes leute was geht ich habe
jetzt gerade noch mal alles
zusammengerechnet und komme auf
tatsächlich doch 961 euro das hätte ich
nicht gedacht aber ich habe auch die
drei kopfhörer mit 68 euro berechnet und
das ist einfach kein realistischer preis
finde ich dafür
deswegen aber trotzdem geht es ja klar
also ich dachte wir liegen 2 700 zwar
nicht wie beschrieben bei mindestens
1000 aber ich will jetzt auch nicht
rummeckern besser als nix also schon
ganz gut gelaufen dieser rasierer zum
beispiel wird halt auch für 190 euro
oder so verkauft das wusste ich nicht
also das nächste paket ich kann euch
versprechen wäre die teuerste mystery
box oder überraschungs wurde natürlich
was auch immer de im deutschsprachigen
raum geöffnet wurde
jetzt lehne ich mich vielleicht ein
bisschen zu weit aus dem fenster aber
ich glaube schon also da werde ich auf
save über zwei ich glaube das sollte war
von rob und dima 2000 euro das wären wir
über bieten seit gern mit am start
lasten daumen nach oben da aber mir zu
packen den kanal dank fürs zuschauen
leute und wir sehen uns übermorgen gibts
neues video
ich hoffe es hat euch halbwegs gefallen
haut rein